hey yo so uh you you put out this new
record with M uh realist like is that
something you're in the studio with him
or is that like a record you have like
tell me the story about that record at
first because like prior like it was
just a regular day like I was working on
songs and that was one of them okay so
the beat are you making your own beats
too right so yeah so you do everything
yeah yeah you record yourself yes no I'm
having to do everything you dance you're
making it I guess rap you sing yeah you
do all that [__] you know
you could do anything man
yeah I'll just try to hone in oh Focus
though but you're working on that record
yeah I had the song basically the first
verse first and the chorus yeah it's
just that and then found out
we went to
you know the studio with Emma Dre that
and I showed them yeah they [__] with it
and then basically after that it was
just a pass back and forth oh wow yeah
so you get the Embers back
that's gotta be it well it's so crazy
like how like I reacted to when I first
listened to it like I was so turned
because I wanted to listen to it again
yeah and then there was like this wait
time not like now I understand
I understand what Boogie felt
what Boogie felt when he got on this
song that's a boogie man yeah West Side
Boogie West Side Boogie's amazing who
were some of your outside of M obviously
like what were some of your like uh
hip-hop influences like what were you
listening to like what are you listening
to like who are your goats like
um
Eminem Kendrick Lamar ASAP Rocky
Tech N9ne Hobson
Snoop Dogg
yup have you seen Tech Nine live yet
nope really
that's uh there's so much like shows
that's like the greatest man I I
wouldn't I wouldn't argue when it comes
to performing he's like the goat he got
that metal background too he's amazing
oh his live show is [__] sick
hopson's sick live
overall like did you see that like his
bait like recently like saying that yeah
yeah that was cool you know yeah it was
smart it went viral yeah he's smart he's
right everybody you got a free chance to
throw [__] at me
and they filmed it at the right time and
it went viral you ever link with Dizzy
Wright in Vegas who's used to be side
with Hopsin Funk Volume
um
funny story actually uh not necessarily
me and um like you know directly like
one of my homeboys that um makes Beats
for me now and I also collaborated with
Michael bars okay
he actually got in recently like
connected with him so there's no MC's
out there dizzy there's a kid named Echo
that's dope
um there's a bunch of dudes in Vegas
that are fire but let's talk you grew up
listening to Hopson and Tech N9 yeah you
got to see Tech live it's like [__]
it's insane yeah I want to man what's
your favorite uh Tech N9ne song or album
Tech N9ne song
strangulation Cipher
with
what's his name Stevie Stone yes TV
Stone and I think Ces Cru is there SAS
crew and
also God they miss
goddamis however you say his name yeah
that one that's my favorite when I heard
that there was all just like spazzing
back to back to back to back to back you
ever heard the Eminem song that Tech did
with him
oh come on that too that [__] crazy yeah
that's for real like
that's super dope yeah yo honestly you
see him live and it'll Inspire your live
show like you're probably already
amazing live because you come from your
background that you come from and you
dance and you do so much but I'm down to
learn for sure like breath control alone
bro his [__] is nasty yeah get it it's
super super Gnar